hi everyone and welcome to biology
professor we have something to celebrate
today I got the idea to start this
channel and fall of 2013 I posted my
very first video on YouTube in January
2014 and now about three and a half
years later this channel has received 1
million views distributed across the
various videos that are hosted on this
channel I was really really excited when
this happened I was watching all through
August waiting for it the million view
came sometime in early September over
Labor Day weekend it was very very
exciting as of today biology professor
has almost 10,000 subscribers so thanks
to all of you who are regularly watching
my videos I want to take a minute to say
thank you to everyone who has watched my
videos and supported this journey I hope
you've learned a lot I plan to continue
posting more videos in the future to
keep spreading the love of biology
education I want to take a brief moment
to highlight my top 4 videos so these
are the ones that have gotten the most
views of all of my videos and those are
gram positive bacteria vs. gram-negative
bacteria the Gram stain procedure
Mendel's law of independent assortment
and Mendel's law of segregation so if
you are interested in any of these and
you haven't already watched these videos
go ahead and check them out now thanks
for watching biology professor and I
hope that you'll be back in the future
bye
you